[موسيقى]
ام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قال افيغدور
ليبرمان زعيم حزب اسرائيل بيتنا رئيس لجنه
الخارجيه والامن في الكنيست ان المفاوضات
الحاليه مع الفلسطينيين لن تنهي الصراع
واعتبر ان الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
ليس شريكا في عمليه السلام
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في المحورين
ما مغزى تصريحات ليبرمان من حيث المحتوى
وتوقيت وما اثارها على مسار المفاوضات
كيف سيستعيد الفلسطينيون المرحله المقبله
بعد انعكست التصريحات جزءا من نوايا
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
لم يكتفي افيكدور ليبرمان بالحديث عن
المفاوضات والسلام ورايه في الرئيس
الفلسطيني بل وصل في تصريحاته الى حد
المطالبه بوقف ما سماه تحريض في وسائل
الاعلام الفلسطينيه والمناهج الدراسيه فهي
كما يقول ليبرمان لا تشمل الخريطه
لاسرائيل ولا توجد فيها كلمه واحده عن
المحرقه واضاف ان المفاوضات لن تنهي
الصراع طالما استمر هذا التحريض من جانب
الفلسطينيين وطالب اسرائيل بتعميق التعاون
مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
في مجال الامن والاقتصاد
مجددا يعود ليبرمان الى لعبته الاخيره
تهديد الفلسطينيين والضغط على سلطتهم
لقبول ما يعرض عليهم حتى لو كان قليلا
الرجل خارج صنع القرار حاليا لكنه لم
يغادر دائره النفوذ من خلال موقعه في
رئاسه لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه والامن في
الكنيست يرى ليبرمان ان محمود عباس ليس
شريكا للسلام
وتلك ليست المره الاولى التي يصف فيها
عباس بذلك على ان الاهم في تصريحات
ليبرمان الاخيره قوله ان المفاوضات
الجاريه مع الفلسطينيين لن تؤدي الى حل
نهائي للصراع وعلى العالم ان لا يهم نفسه
بامكانيه ذلك وجل ما يمكن تقديمه هنا هو
تعميق التعاون مع السلطه في مجالي الامن
والاقتصاد تلك هي اطروحتنا تن ياه
الاساسيه دوله على نحو بعين في المائه من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مقابل حوافز اقتصاديه
وتسهيلات اوسع لما يعتبرها تجمعات سكانيه
في الجوار يشير مسار المفاوضات بين
الفلسطينيين واسرائيل الى مراوحه في
المكان رغم ما يوحي به من حركه بمفاوضات
عباس مع اولمرت لم تنتهي الى الحد الادنى
الذي يريده الفلسطينيون توقفت المفاوضات
ثلاث سنوات ليعلن عن استئنافها في تموز
يوليو الماضي بعد جولات مكوكيه مكثفه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي اتفق الطرفان
انذاك على ان تكون مده المفاوضات ما بين 6
و 9 اشهر يجمد خلالها الفلسطينيون
الانضمام لاي من المنظمات الدوليه ومن
بينها محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
ومنذ ذلك الوقت عقدت عده جولات من
المفاوضات وسط تكتم شديد لكن اسرائيل لم
تتوقف في الاثناء عن التوسع الاستيطاني
ولم يكن هذا وحده ما يؤرق المعنيين بل
تراجع قوه الدفع المصاحبه ل لعمليه وتغير
اولويات اسرائيل نفسها لا ياتيهم تهديد من
الجوار الفلسطيني ليفكروا في سبل حله بل
من منطقه اخرى طهران وقد انفتحت على الغرب
وان فتح عليها
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اريح
الدكتور صائب عريقات وعضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه ورئيس دائره المفاوضات في منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه
ومن رام الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
مع مرحبا بكم ضيفينا الكريمين للتو صائب
عريقات
كيف تلقيتم هذه التصريحات منا بدون
ليبرمان
مساء الخير اخ ناصر ومساء الخير دكتور
مصطفى اه في الحقيقه لم نفاجئ بهذه
التصريحات اه اه ليبرمان اه هو شريك اساسي
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه بل الانتخابات
الاخيره كان هو على لائحه واحدا مع حزب
الليكود وهو بالتالي ليس خارج القرار هو
جزء من القرار الاسرائيلي اه ليبرمان يبعث
برسائل الخطيه والذين نسخ منها اه تقول ان
الرئيس محمود عباس الشريك بل اكثر من ذلك
في رسائل الداخليه وعندنا نسخه منها تقول
يجب التخلص من الرئيس محمود عباس انه يصر
على حقوق اللاجئين بالعوده وعلى القدس
الشرقيه عاصمه لفلسطين وهذا يذكره اه
حرفيا وانه لا يريد السلام وريد الارث
التاريخي ان يكون غير ذلك وهذا كلام حقيقه
اه يحمل في طياته التحريض خطير على الرئيس
اه محمود عباس اه
في دور المسجد يا
وانما موقف ربما يعبر عن اه اه اه موقف
جماعي للحكومه او نتانياهو حكومته
اه في الحقيقه ال المساله في هذه الحكومه
يعني سؤال ان هذه الحكومه يعني اه قد يسال
سائل يعني انتم تقولون ليبرمان وهي حكومه
من المستوطنين و للمستوطنين وبال مستوطن
اذا لماذا استانفت المفاوضات مع هذه
الحكومه وهذا سؤال حقيقه يعني سؤال صحيح و
شرعي ولكن قبل ان اخذ في الاجابه على هذا
السؤال يجيب عليه اه التصريحات ليبرمان
ليس فقط تصريحات ليه يعني هناك نهج اه في
الاملاءات والاغتيالات والاعتقالات وحصار
قطاع غزه وفرض الحقائق على الارض ما تعرض
المسجد الاقصى له مؤخرا كلها ان دلت على
شيء تدل على انه هذه الحكومه تريد ان تدمر
هذه الفرصه التي اعطيت لعمليه السلام من
قبل المجتمع الدولي لا اقول الاداره
الامريكيه واحده ولكن اقول من قبل المجتمع
الدولي اه بالكامل وباعتقادي انه اذا
استمرت يعني اسرائيل في هذا النهج
التدميري اه فهي اه الاقوال عن الرئيس ابو
مازن وعدم جديد هو التخلص منه اضافه الى
المستوطنات والاملاءات على الارض تعنيان
امرا واحدا امرا واحدا الا وهو اه وقف هذه
المفاوضات والقاء اللوم على الجانب
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني اذا ما هو قام بمثل
هذه الخطوه والتي قد تحدث اذا ما استمرت
هذه العمليات الاسرائيليه وهذه الافعال
الاسرائيليه دكتور اه مصطفى البرغوثي اه
كيف اه يعني تقر انت في تصريحات دور
ليبرمان
الواقع ان هذه التصريحات ليست مفصوله عن
كامله يقودها نتنياهو بنفسه الجوقه مكونه
من نتانياهو من لبيد وليبرمان وداني دان
ونفتالي بينيت
جميعهم اه متطرفين وعن سوريين وجميعهم
يطلب هذه التصريحات برايك جزء من عمليه
التفاوض الجاريه اه ولهم هدفان الهدف
الاول هو اه العمل على تاكيد رفض اتفاق
دائم ونهائي اي رفض اي شيء يمكن ان يؤدي
الى حريه واستقلال الفلسطينيين والضغط على
الجانب الفلسطيني للقبول باتفاق جزئي
انتقالي جديد اه هدفه في نهايه المطاف كما
يقول ليبرمان تكريس تعاون اقتصادي وامني
اي تكريس منظومه حكم ذاتي هزيل وليس دوله
حقيقيه وان تكون السلطه وكيل امني
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي باختصار هو يروج
لفكره دوله الحدود المؤقته ويستخدم هذه
التصريحات من اجل الضغط في هذا الاتجاه
وما نراه هنا تطبيق واض واضح وصريح لما
اسميها نادين الحركه الصهيونيه اه
وممارستها السياسيه وهو قائم على تجزئه
القضايا اولا ثم تاجيلها ثانيا تمت تصفيته
ثالثا وهذا بالضبط النهج الذي يتبعه في
اوسلو الهدف الثاني الذي يمارس هذا
تمارسها وبرايي بقياده نتنياهو شخصيا هو
الضغط النفسي والابتزاز السياسي ضد السلطه
الفلسطينيه وضد الجانب الفلسطيني في
محاوله لدفع هم لتقديم تنازلات يرمي الكره
في المرمى الفلسطيني
ولذلك يجري الحديث عن التحريض وعن المناهج
وعن الاسميه وليست تصريحات ليبرمان خفيفه
بالنسبه ل ما ادلى به النفط الابيض مؤخرا
في محاضره في واشنطن عندما تحدث عن ان
المشكله ليست مشكله الحدود والمستوطنات
والقدس المشكله ان الفلسطينيه المصابين
بمرض الكراهيه وقال ان الوصفه لعلاج هم ان
الفلسطينيين يحتاج الى اطباء نفسيين
لمعالجه هذه المشكله الاثنان كما تلاحظ
يسيران في نفس الايه هناك تصريحات سياسيه
بين الاطراف المشكله للحكومه وبالتالي هو
موقف اه يعبر عن اه عن اه اه نوايا معينه
ولكن هناك الحلقات هنا هناك يعني اين
وصلتم انتم الدكتور صائب عريقات اين وصلتم
في جولات المفاوضه اه المفاوضات السابقه
حتى ربما يصل الموقف الاسرائيلي الى اه اه
ربما هذا الموقف الذي قاد ينظر اليه على
انه نوع من الضغط عليكم ماذا في حقيقه
الامر
منكم تقديم تنازلات جديده
يعني في الحقيقه باعتقادي انه الان يعني
ثبت القاصي والداني انه عندما يقول للرئيس
محمود عباس كما قال الرئيس ياسر عرفات كما
تقول كل قياده الشعب الفلسطيني نحن نسعى
للسلام ونريد السلام ولكن سلام لن يكون
باي ثمن سلامنا يقوم على اساس تنفيذ
القانون الدولي وافعاله انسحاب اسرائيل
لخط اربع حزيران سبعه وستين القدس الشرقيه
عاصمه لفلسطين
هذا معروف ولكن ولكن
اخر جوله من المفاوضات حتى ربما يدفع
الطرف الاسرائيلي اللي صار في المصري الان
يعني انا لا اريد الخوض في الجولات
التفاوضيه مصر ولكن كل ما اقول لك انه اذا
ارادت اسرائيل ان تنهي الصراع فعليها ان
لا تتحدث عن مناهج واكاذيب وتحريض كما
يفعل ليبرمان ولا بيدو غيره عليها ان تقر
بانه اه وجوب انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انسحاب اسرائيل خط اربع حزيران سبعه وستين
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه هذه ال حل قضيه
اللاجئين كما قلت دوله العلاقه وحده
القرار مائه واربعه وتسعين الافراج عن
الاسرى والمعتقلين
هذه مسائل ال اقر هذا القانون الدولي
والان مرجعيه المفاوضات تقوم على اساس
القرار الدولي الذي اتخذ في تسعه وعشرين
نوفمبر 2012 ان دوله فلسطين على حدود سبعه
وستين عاصمه القدس الشرقيه دوله احتلال
كما تماما كموقع دول كثيره تحت الاحتلال
البرلمان الياباني في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
دكتور نريد ان اعرف الجديد يعني هل هل
صحيح ما تناولته بعض الصحف وبعض اه اه ال
المصادر الاعلاميه على ان المفاوضات وصلت
الى طريق مسدود حينما اه يعني رفضتم انتم
ان اه اه لا تس تس ان ان تسيطر اسرائيل
على المعابر الحدوديه مع الاردن
اه اه يعني كل يوم اخ ناصر هناك تسريبات
في وسائل الاعلام
وهناك كل ما قراته حتى اليوم هناك تسريب
اخر الى وسائل الاعلام على الانساني اه
كله لا اساس له من الصحه كل لا اساس له من
الصحه
القول ان المفاوضات اه اه اه ال اه كما
قلت لك يعني مساله تبادل الاراضي هي مساله
تتم بين الدول ذات سياده احنا شعب تحت
احتلال وبالتالي الذي اه تبادل الاراضي تم
على سبيل المثال بين الولايات المتحده
وكندا من المتحده والمكسيك بيرو يكون دور
الاردن والسعوديه عام الف وتسعمائه وخمسه
وستين تبادلا تسعه وعشرين كيلومتر مربع
وكذلك فعل العراق والاردن
عندما عندما صحيفه معاريف قبل نحو اسبوع
حينما قالت بانكم انتم وافقتم على ان تسلم
كم اسرائيل اه بعض اه الاراضي في القدس
الشرقيه على ان تتسلمها انتم اه اه بعض
الاراضي في نابلس
هذا غير صحيح على الاطلاق القدس الشرقيه
منطقه محتله كما ماك نابلس وبالتالي كما
قتل خمسه وتسعين في المائه من السلوك
التفاوض الاسرائيلي هو ما يتم عبر
التسريبات ووسائل الاعلام وتشويه السمعه
والتحريض وللاسف هناك الكثير مما يعتمد ع
ما تقول وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وكانه
امور سابقه وامور منزله ال ال الذي اريد
ان اقوله نحن دخلنا الى المفاوضات ليس
بدنا نتفاهم مع اسرائيل دخلنا الى هذه
المفاوضات بناءا تفاهم على الاداره
الامريكيه واعضاء اللجنه الرباعيه والعالم
اجمع وبالتالي الاستراتيجيه الفلسطينيه
الان نحن دوله تحت الاحتلال
المفاوضات مرجعيتها الانسحاب ال خط اربع
حزيران سبعه وستين اعطيت فرصه نعم تسعه
اشهر في هذه المفاوضات وكان هناك التزام
منا بعدم الذهاب المؤسسات الدوليه مقابل
الافراج عن مائه واربعه عشره فلسطينيين
قبل وصل هذا صحيح اه وبالتالي يعني ال ال
الاتفاق من الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بالتوجهات الاوروبيه الخاصه بالاستيطان
وانشاء العالم كله سيتبع ذلك اه هناك امور
اخرى تتعلق برفض الولايات المتحده الحل
الجزئي والانتقالي
واتفاقا مع الاداره الامريكيه من حل سيشمل
كل القضايا الوضع وعلى راسها القدس
واللاجئين والافراج عن الاسرى وهذا كله اه
مع الولايات المتحده وروسيا والامم
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي والدول العربيه
كانت ايضا طرف اه في ذلك من خلال لجنه
متابعه مبادره السلام العربيه
الان اه الجانب الاسرائيلي يعني في يعمل
خمسه وتسعين في المائه من سلوك التفاوض
عبر رفع الاستيطان منذ ثلاثين تموز الى
الان بنسبه اثنين وثمانين في المائه هناك
11 شهيد
قدمت هناك اه تم رصد في الاقصى المبارك
وكلها تدل على شيء وكان حكومه تريد ان
تدمر الفرصه التي اعطيت لعمليه السلام
وانا اقول انه قد تنجح اسرائيل في اه ب
استمرت هذه السياسات بامتناع عن الذهاب
ولكن هي التي ستتحمل مسؤوليه هذا المعيار
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي كيف يفترض ان يكون
رد الفعل الفلسطيني على مثل هذه التصريحات
او على هذا التوجه اه الساعي الى هدم هذه
العمليه اصلا و اه اه والهم الفلسطيني كما
بدا من اشاره الدكتور صائب عريقات وكان
يريد ان يعني الطرف الامريكي حينما يذهب
الى مفاوضات يعلم مسبقا انه اه انها لن
تكون مجديه
كل الارقام التي ذكرها الدكتور صائب
عريقات وعمليات القمع والتنكيل والتصريحات
الاسرائيليه تدل على عبثيه المفاوضات
الجاريه التي يخوضونها وتدل على عبثيه
المراهنه اصلا على امكانيه الوصول الى
النتائج مع حكومه المستوطنين المستوطنين
والتطرف العنصري ولكن هناك ثمن لهذه
المفاوضات هذه المفاوضات لا تجري دون ثمن
اه اسرائيل تكسب الوقت وتستغل الوقت
لتكريس الاستيطان وتستغل الوقت لتوسيع
عمليات القمع والتنكيل والاعتقال ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
افرجوا عن سته وعشرين اسير واعتقلوا مئات
اه اسرائيل الان لجنه التشريعات في
الكنيسيت اجتمعت لتمرير قانون يحرم
امكانيه التنازل عن اي شبر في القدس اه
كما يسمونه تنازل وهي اراضي محتله ان
يعيدوها الى الفلسطينيين يحرم ذلك ويدعو
الى قرار اه انه لا يمكن تغيير هذا الواقع
الا بتصويت ثلثي الكنيسيت عليه وهذا
مستحيل نحن نتحدث عن عمليه تكسب من وراءها
اسرائيل الكثير ولذلك يجب تغييرها يجب
وقفها يجب تبني نهج بديل نحن بحاجه الى
استراتيجيه بديله الاستراتيجيه البديله
يجب ان تستند الى ان يشعر الشعب الفلسطيني
ان قياده غيرت المسار وان نسير في اتجاه
فعلا تصعيد المقاومه الشعبيه بكل اشكالها
ان ن ستعيدون فتح معركه الامم المتحده
فورا وان تاخذ اسرائيل الى محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه التي تحاكم على جرائم الحرب التي
ترتكبها بما في ذلك جريمه الاستيطان وان
نوحد الصف الوطني وان
على التصعيد حمله المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات
لولا حمله المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات الشعبيه
التي جرت في العالم وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي
لما جرى تغيير في موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي
واتخذوا هذا القرار بالزام اسرائيل
باستثناء المستوطنات والقدس من الاتفاق
السلطه الفلسطينيه ب حرصها على على مسار
تفاوضي الذي اثبت الزمن انه غير مجدي ربما
قد يحسب على اه السلطه انها هي التي اوقفت
هذا المسار اذا ما يعني ربما اه اه اه كان
هذا الدفاع العكسي هناك طبعا اه نحن نفهم
ان هناك اجتهاد وراءه او هدفه القول بانه
في ظل الظروف العربيه القائمه الهدف اظهار
ان الجانب الفلسطيني جدي وان الاسرائيليين
المسؤولين ولكن انا اؤكد لك من الان وحمله
التحريض الجاريه الان هي استباق اسرائيلي
لامكانيه ان يقنع الفلسطينيون للعالم
بانهم هم الجنديين واسرائيل غير جديه الان
اسرائيل تتحدث عن معاداه الساميه اه اه لا
بيد يقول ان الف من من يدعم الفلسطينيين
ودعم الارهاب ويقول المعركه ليست من يجب
بين جوليا توظيف اه لان الاسرائيليين
اقوياء وان ما يشبه الفلسطينيين بالقاعده
نحن نتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه ونفسيه
اسرائيليه لاسرائيل ليست دوله غربيه
ولديها مخططين وعلماء ومفكرين وبالتالي هم
يستبقوا الموقف الفلسطيني من الان بالتالي
لماذا نضيع مزيد من الوقت لماذا لان تبني
استراتيجيه بديله خصوصا عندما ذهبنا الى
الامم المتحده وضعنا اساس لتوحيد موقف
الشعب الفلسطيني وتقديم بديل مقنع له
بصراحه المراهنه على مفاوضات مع حكومه
المستوطنين فاشله و غير مجديه و لن تؤدي
الى النتيجه
في الجزء الثاني اه على الموقف الفلسطيني
كيف يستعد يستعيد بعد ان عكس تصريحات
ليبرمان اه اه يعني لا اقول جزءا من نوايا
الحكومه بل النوايا الحقيقيه لحكومه اه
نتانياهو سنواصل بعد هذا الفاصل مشاهدينا
فابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
انا بكم من جديد الاعتراف في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش وتصريحات ليبرمان بان
المفاوضات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه لم تؤدي
الى حل نهائي للصراع اه الدكتور صائب
عريقات اه قبل ان ارد هالمساله استعدادكم
المرحله القادمه بعجاله
كيف تقرا انت ما قاله ليبرمان حينما
طالبكم بوقف التحريض اه قد يفهم وقت تحرير
وسائل الاعلام ولكن ان يطالب بوقف التحريض
كما قال في المناهج الدراسيه
هو في الحقيقه اخي انا استمعت جيدا الاخ
الدكتور مصطفى وهو وهو شخص يعرف تماما ان
هناك استراتيجيه فلسطينيه وهو جزء في بعض
منها يعني
هو يعرف انه المفاوضات لم تكن ارض ان
الاداره الامريكيه
صحيح الامريكيه لا نريد الصراع معها ولكن
يعرف تماما انه ذهبنا الامم المتحده
بالرغم من الاراده الاداره الامريكيه
ودفعنا ثمان ذلك ويعرف تماما مصطفى وجزء
من من ما اقوله انه الاتحاد الاوروبي لم
يطرح التوجهات الغاز الاستيطان ومقاطعه
منتوجات كل الاتفاقات معه الا عندما
وافقنا على العوده الى المفاوضات وقالوا
الان سيدخل حيز التنفيذ 1 1 2014 اذن نحن
لسنا في جزء من سياسه حارات نقول للناس ما
تحب ان تسمع هناك استراتيجيه فلسطينيه
تقوم اولا على وحده الشعب الفلسطيني واجب
هذه الفوري
يجب ان تتم بشكل فوري ويجب العوده الى
اراده الشعب ولا صندوق الاقتراع بشكل فوري
هذا هذا هذا المسائل في مواجهه ليبرمان
وتحدياته واثنا الامر الثاني انه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وباقي دول العالم التي
اخذت هذه المواقف تجاه الاستيطان وهي
الاولى منذ عام الف وتسعمائه وثمانيه
وستين ونحن اتفقنا معهم ويعرف الاخير
مصطفى وكان جزء منها انه ذهبنا المفاوضات
كان مرهون بهذه المساله الامر الثالث هناك
موقف عربي موحد من كل ما يشهد العالم
العربي من تراجعات ولكن هناك موقف عربي
مدعوم مستند القانون الدولي الشعب الدوليه
واحد منا بالكامل هناك ايضا قضيه الافراج
عن 104 اسرى ما قبل اوسلو
وهذا امر لا يستهان به سته وعشرين الاقل
وثلاثين سنه في السجون الدول التي تحترم
حالها ترسل جيوشها لتحرير ابنائها وهؤلاء
ابناءنا ويجب تحريرهم ان كانت ثم اندفع
فانا
من اجل مصلحه الشعب الفلسطيني من اجل
القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن نقطه الارتكاز
الاساسيه اللي يتفق فيها مع الاخ مصطفى
احنا الان لدينا استراتيجيه عمل تقوم على
اساس دوله فلسطين المحتله حدود سبعه وستين
والمنطقه الشرقيه ان اه اسقطت هذه
المفاوضات بفعل ما تقوم به اسرائيل على
الارض والمماطله تجري فيها خياراتنا
استراتيجيتنا مفتوحه العربيه وستين منظمه
دوليه الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون معنا في تلك
اللحظه العالم اجمع سيكون معنا روسيا
سيكون معنا سيكون معنا امريكا اللاتينيه
اذن نحن
عليه هذا الكلام
الفلسطينيون الشارع ويقولون بان مسار
التفاوض في مسار اوسلو قد مات وانتم هددت
متسابقا بانكم تقفون توقفون اي مسار
تفاوضي الا اذا لم توقف اسرائيل الاستيطان
الاستيطان الماضي توقفت اضغط عليك مره
اخرى والاستيطان وايضا
يعني
صحيح صحيح
هذا صحيح ولكن انظر الى مفاعل الاتحاد
الاوروبي في المستوطنات انظر الى مفاعل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني ارجو من الجميع
ارجو ان تعي ان تقول حلقه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بما يسمى التوجهات القائد العزيز
الاوروبيه
اه سيدي ناصر اذا ما القضيه
القضيه
هذه الارض المحتله
هذه ارض محتله هذا الاستيطان قام عرض
المحتله في الضفه والقدس واذا اوروبا
مصادره هذا المشروع اسباني سينهار وهذا
اهم تطور حدث منذ عام الف وتسعمائه وستين
فلسطين لن تحرر بشعار
تنفسهم من جهه اخرى دكتور وانت تعلم ذلك
جيدا
اسمح لي انا الامر اصبح يعني مكررا
كيف يفترض ان يكون السداد الفلسطيني لمثل
هذه
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه القائمه على
تخفيف نهائيه المسار التفاوضي
واه اه بينما على الارض هناك سياسه واقعيه
تقوم على ال ال ابتلاع الارض يوما بعد يوم
اه اولا عندما نتحدث عن استبدال هذا النهج
نحن لا نتحدث عن سياسه الحراره كما قال
الدكتور صائب انا اليوم كنت في قريه في
نابلس ماذا سيقال لهؤلاء المزارعين الذين
قطع الاسرائيليون اشجار هم من جذورها ماذا
اقول لامراه كانت تقف هناك بين اجارها
وتسمع ان هناك مفاوضات وترى امامها
الاستيطاني يتسع كل لحظه لذلك كان هناك
موقف عليه اجماع منا جميعا بانه لا يجوز
ان يجري تفاوض نوقف الاستيطان للاسف جرى
اه الخروج عن ذلك اليوم المساله ليست صراع
بيننا المساله ما هو مستقبل الشعب
الفلسطيني وقضيته وهي اكبر بكثير من اي
اختلاف داخلي المساله الان ماذا نفعل
الدكتور صائب يعرف وهو استاذ علوم سياسيه
انه اي مفاوضات في العالم تقررها في
النهايه ليس الكلمات وليس الفصاحه وليس
الشعارات تقرر نتيجتها موازين القوى
القائمه ميزان القوى القائم مختل غير
صالحنا باعتراف الجميع وهذا يقدم كمبرر
المفاوضات انا اقول ان التركيز يجب ان
يكون على تغيير ميزان القوى هل هذا ممكن
بالتاكيد هل هذه الاستراتيجيه قابله
للتحقيق بالتاكيد لوضع الجميع قواهم
وطاقاتهم في اتجاه المقاومه الشعبيه وهذا
ليس امر غير واقعي هذا شيء يمكن ان يشارك
فيه كل الناس لو شعر الناس ان كل قيادات
هو متجهه في هذا الاتجاه لو شددنا حمله
المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات وبالضبط استانفنا
معركه الامم المتحده عندما ذهبنا للتحدث
حصل شيء اعاد مع الفلسطينيين بعد ان كانوا
قد تمزقوا بسبب اتفاق اوسلو اليوم نحن
بحاجه الى جامع وطني فلسطيني مشترك
المفاوضات تقسمنا ولا توحدنا ونحن بحاجه
الى شيء يجمعنا لانني متاكد كل ما تقوم به
اسرائيل الان ماذا يستهدف تصفيه قضيه
القدس تصفيه حق اللاجئين في العوده هل
هناك فلسطيني يستطيع ان يقول انه مستعد ان
يتنازل عن حق اللاجئين في العوده يريد ان
يستهدفوا حتى حقنا في اقامه دوله مستقله
ولذلك يريد ان يبقوا قواتهم في الغرب وفي
كل المناطق
يعني الان البيت ما مواقع ان اسرائيل تفرض
عليكم معادله جديده بدل الارض مقابل
السلام الامن المقابل الاقتصاد او السلام
الاقتصاد
انا انا انا كل الاحترام للدكتور مصطفى
ولم اخر
ولكن يقولوا العيب ليس في ال اه السعيد
الى السلام العيب في الاستيطان
والمستوطنات والاملاءات واوصى الشعب
الفلسطيني ان لكم سبعه وثلاثين كيلومتر
على البحر الميت حقوقها في الاردن القدس
الشرقيه عاصمتهم سته واربعين كيلومتر في
منطقه ثلاث مناطق حرام اربعه كيلو مترا في
القدس الشرقيه
في العوده اياكم انتقاد حق بحق نحن الان
نخوض سياسه ولم نكن مدعومين معززين كما
نحن عليه الان من العالم اجمع واصواتها في
الامم المتحده واضحه ومحدده هذا جاء نتيجه
ل تجاوبنا مع العالم العالم يريد من ان
المفاوضات مضحك ندفع ثمن طاهر وهذا صحيح
ولكننا نكسب نكسب اوروبا يعني
ان تكون معنا نعم الشعب الشعب الفلسطيني
يبقى على ارضه معززه
الدكتور علي السلام ولكن سلام الدكتور
اه عضو المج التنفيذيه والرئيس الى
المفاوضات في منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك اشكر ايضا الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
وشكرا مشاهدين الكرام لمتابعتكم والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
ام
[موسيقى]